[Music]
so
i have this survey in front of me that
says or that they found
that from the year 2000 to 2018
nearly one in three u.s
men aged 18 to 24
reported no sexual activity in the past
year simps [ __ ] sips
what was the year again 2000 to 2018.
oh so 18 years
they found that men aged 18 to 24
1 and 3 are not having any sex for a
whole year
for a whole year that makes sense that
doesn't count even yourself is yourself
is that considered a sexual activity no
so they're saying like being intimate
with someone else and they're saying
that
a reason to this trend
is because of the fact that there's a
prevalence of other forms
of solo entertainment oh porno so there
was a spike in
masturbation because of the sweet porn
that was coming out during this time
like that's what they're insinuating and
they're also saying that there's way
more
there's a lot more choices of things to
do
for you to spend your time rather than
having sex with your partner you could
be binge watching
you could be on social media you could
be video gaming and
it's just all these how many dudes have
jerked off too much in a week where
you're like this is too stupid and crazy
i
was literally had college days yeah i
was going crazy in my mid-20s i'm like
bro
yeah that's where i developed my
ideology where i'm like i can't drink up
that much this is crazy
i was having pains like two weeks ago
good for you masturbating too much where
uh only when i would come
that it would be almost a little bit
it'd be like yeah
and i was like what the [ __ ] is going on
and uh it was yeah because
it was like that too much and then the
opposite happened so i was like all
right cool i'm not gonna jack off and
then in the middle of the night i'll
wake up like
so [ __ ] horny and like kind of like
you were talking about earlier like your
dick's pressing against the sheets or
you're gonna feel so good no it hurts
because it's there's not that much room
in the underwear you gave your dick
scoliosis
you have a curve now i need to buy
bigger underwear not that there's
anything wrong with that oh because you
have one right
i forgot and i was like i'm not going to
do it right because i was trying not to
and then i started developing other
pains like uh not like right above my
groin and i was like
what the [ __ ] are like deep in my balls
and then it was literally for uh you
could get pain from being so
like built up yeah your constipated
difference being backed up or something
yeah but not only backed up uh because
i've been backed up and it's fine but
just being so like
that night was like so much that and
then not doing anything about it
caused the pain how do you win too right
so the other night
i was having sex with with nikki limo uh
green from the internet
and i was like i know her she's really
nice and i know who she is
i came rather quick because we had sex
in like nine days
and i hadn't jerked off at all like
other than
i think like five days before that maybe
they're gonna say other than like
five or ten times no like five days
before that so and i told her about it
too i was like yo i
had to jerk off today you're [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] you
why is it her fault no it's not it's not
but i was just down to [ __ ] and then she
was like
in the moment she was not down and so i
had to jerk off but point being
i came very quick and then she
challenged me after that she was like
oh well you're going to come that fast
and [ __ ] and then
last night i [ __ ] wrecked that stupid
[ __ ]
i jerked off in the morning yes oh you
killed it
doesn't matter you're cheating i'm
telling nikki he's planning his day out
ahead of time
he's that night i carpet bomb that [ __ ]
so
hard oh my this [ __ ] never had a chance
of course not you cheated she couldn't
come to jk newsday she had to cancel
uh yeah man that's that's a struggle i
remember
i mean even as a married man and like
and whenever i make jokes about like
jerking off on twitter or whatever
people like why are you drinking off
you're married i'm like bruh
like sometimes you just feel like
drinking off you know they just don't
want to [ __ ] every second
i know and you know and here's the thing
and neither do i but like sometimes like
i think
now after being married for a couple
years it's kind of like okay
cool we had sex this week or um and it's
like
maybe she doesn't feel like it right now
after a couple days i'll be like all
right babe well
i'm gonna jerk off and she's like okay
cool and
but but then also she's like oh okay
well or you know or we can have sex i'm
like oh okay cool but i'll throw it out
there like hey babe it's been a couple
days i'm
it's about time for me to bust a nut and
um if she's not feeling it then cool
i'll drink off and it's all love
and that's so mature because like by the
way there's so many variables
it's like oh my wife just started a
period today and she's like hey look i
can't [ __ ] up my period it hurts too
much and it's like okay well i'll wait
and she's like well i don't wanna be
gross for you and say
okay well i'll wait three days and it's
like okay well it's the third day like
what's going on and then she's like well
you know
i have cramps or whatever who cares it
doesn't matter but yeah there's a lot of
variables that people have
and i tried to do what what nadine did
one time where it's like let's see how
long i can go without like drinking off
and after like
two weeks and i think it's because
you're you're messing up your routine
you know what i'm saying and after like
two weeks but this is when i was like in
college and [ __ ] too
i'm just feeling like i couldn't even
think you know i felt like the jizz went
into my brain it was clouding my
my literally how the it's routed you
know what's crazy though if you wait
past
that period yes you actually lose
yourself no you don't
i swear to god what do you mean you lose
yourself so for me no
when i'm when i'm having a healthy sex
life i have morning wood
every [ __ ] morning no matter [ __ ]
because
you're not you can have sex not jack off
though wait what's healthy to you are
you like cutting me
cutting sex in general no he said what
i'm doing ejaculation regardless of how
it happens
what i'm saying is if it's a regular
thing it's like every three days i have
morning wood
all the [ __ ] time yeah and so me and
geo we have a rule because we're trying
to build our intimacy what it's uh
for all of like 2018 2019 we i can't
jack off more than the times that we
have sex
so if we have sex we can jack off that
week if not we
so like our intimacy can't our personal
intimacy can't overshadow our
relationship intimacy
that's the rule okay i really like that
rule so we stuck to that um but
sometimes we'll go through some
crazy [ __ ] there's like business
happening here i'm traveling or whatever
so there was a time where it was like
over uh my brain starts getting clouded
because i didn't bust a nut for like a
month
and then it'll be maybe like two months
and then i start realizing
oh [ __ ] two months with no nuts yeah
exactly wait really yeah and i'm like oh
[ __ ]
there's no morning wood
whatsoever and that part starts to worry
me i could never because i'm like that
is [ __ ] crazy it's like out of the
door
too many we're gonna lose it i get it i
mean it's never 180.
that's how i know you have a buddhist
mother yeah
no because even like on the girls side
for example like if it ends up being
a really long time of nothing going in
there that shit's like shutting
up like it's like getting tighter and
tighter and tighter and it feels like
losing your virginity again but it's
kind of beautiful for
us at least no because it's painful too
apparently we got sick for like two
months and we barely [ __ ]
and then when i got back in there it was
like i was [ __ ] the virgin [ __ ]
again
this is awesome how do we replicate this
you can't also i know you can't have
your cake and eat it too it's gonna wait
well if only she did more kegels i think
it actually really is true it really is
true right
that's what she was saying on news last
time too i wish you all knew so we could
all bro five about it
oh you did wish that they knew it sucks
so you guys didn't get to [ __ ] nikki
before
it really sucks it sucks you really suck
i really think he's a good friend
thank you let's consider it well he's
not offering after no i'm not saying
that he's just saying he wishes
was that one lyric yeah something about
it ain't no fun if the homies can't have
nothing
you knew you know isn't that true stupid
what about you julia do you do you agree
you want to make out with me
do you agree that um i'm not the one
bringing it out it feels like you're
virgin again
i would say so i would say it feels
pretty exciting
but i'm not gonna say any more than that
because i know that uh you've told too
many stories here
well no i don't know i just out of
respect for my boyfriend i don't think
he wants to share this i don't think i
don't it was out of spite i don't think
he would have said that
he'd been over my face and farted in my
face when i was asleep good point
but that's harmless she has cantonese
logic too so it's different
it's like we could throw boogers at each
other yeah out of respect for my
boyfriend i would [ __ ] deem with the
strength
she was like name the time this is more
intimate like sex between us is more
intimate
i want to be between you strapping that
does on you in order you get it
we'll see if it's between me and you i
mean i can talk about it you have
to oh i see no i refrain from getting
into uh details about about me and csx
too you know i don't respect
yeah out of respect i mean i would [ __ ]
you with a strap on yeah but yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah however she had
sex details i mean you know
yeah yeah you get it yeah i get it i
don't get it
two months with no nut is crazy it was
crazy dude
it's crazy i mean was that post
pregnancy [ __ ] yes so we were going
was it post right that's so reasonable
oh it could be it could be could have
been that time have you done between
seven and nine months of her being
pregnant
you guys had sex yeah we still had sex
oh [ __ ] it's it's a different experience
tell you that much what do you mean
well it's like you're [ __ ] a sumo
wrestler when she was seven months
pregnant oh
like it's it's it's also different when
you know you have a you already have one
in the chamber and then you're like and
you're having another one in the chamber
you're like wait am i double jabbing
what the hell is going on in here like
is this double jeopardy
you're getting inside of your own head
it does though you can't you can't help
because the belly's right there right so
you're like okay what's going on
oh you had the belly face up you got a
spoon at that point well you know you
just tried different things though you
got it it's just it's
i mean i don't know how big your dick is
yeah if you're a big dick privilege
i'm sorry i'm not saying anything bad
but but
yeah i mean the two months it was i
think we're just working on things and
it was tough but
like i think we have a rule so we try to
stick really hard to the rule no matter
what
which is what the rule which is not uh
having
not jacking off more than the times that
we have honestly that's really good
yeah that's cool i like that role maybe
i'll implement it in my marriage too
because i also do believe because i
don't know how hard it is for girls to
understand why guys need to jack up
where some guys have to jack up they
don't have enough sex or whatever
so um it's like i think sex can be on a
guy's mind like 24 7.
sure so i think some having some sort of
other release
does help out because i don't think the
libido matches most of the time i think
it's also good for your prostate it's
healthy like guys are supposed to
like consistently bust your nut
yeah yeah isn't it wow that we're
supposed to come so many times
and so many different chicks to
repopulate the earth that's what we're
supposed to do right so that's
we're like we're populated enough too
tell me about it that's where i'm like
but your biology doesn't know that
that's the problem
biology relaxed that you try to evolve
right chill yeah
the ios update yeah it's like we say
i'll update later
later every time every time remind me
[Music]
tomorrow
you